14h30 une soixantaine de gilet jaune
arrive devant la préfecture de belfort
dans l'espoir de rencontrer la préfète
en vain au gouvernement de tournedos
matrone tourner aux dons maintenant je
vais demander devant la préfecture et
sud pâtissent de la tournée dont la
mobilisation a débuté plus tôt dans la
matinée des manifestants se sont
rassemblés sur ce parking de bessoncourt
là où les gilets jaunes s'étaient donné
rendez vous pour la toute première fois
objectif dresser le bilan de la journée
d'hier est organisée celle d'aujourd'hui
parmi les points de blocages décidés les
accès à cette station service située à
belfort et le parking du leclerc
aucun automobiliste n'est autorisé à y
entrer
même si là je vais avec mes enfants au
cinéma je les soutiens parce que c'est
c'est pour tout le monde c'est pas que
le gasoil c'est pourquoi tout général ai
ras-le-bol
on est déterminés on lâchera pas macron
devra lâcher il ya du monde derrière
mais ce qu'il ya du monde ici
[Applaudissements]
et pour rallier encore plus de monde
direction le marché des vosges là bas
des manifestants distribuent des tracts
auprès des clients et des commerçants de
la ville de langfang soyons dont
continuons soyaux 2 bis avait mobilisé
en 30 août la ville de belfort ainsi que
tous les citoyens donc de france pour
continuer à se battre pour un monde
meilleur et pour nous
noélie pauvres retraités qui n'auront
vraiment pas de salaire indécent qu'un
gâteau
aujourd'hui la nuit à 21h30
légis les jeunes bloqueurs ont à nouveau
le péage de fontaine puis les chauffeurs
de poids lourds devraient prendre le
relais lundi matin